so
we looked at book one last class session
and in book one of the on the nature of
the gods we get the
characters being set up and you get
introduced to them and you you figure
out hey this guy's an epicurean this
guy's an academic this guy's a stoic
and you have some general idea about
what that means
and then the epicurean does his swung
and dance
and attacks everybody else and their
viewpoints
and then presents his own and then kata
the academic
he criticizes the epicureans point of
view
and one of the things i'd like to tell
you about cicero considered the
epicureans in certain respects kind of
philosophical lightweights
they were one of the really important
schools of philosophy at his time
and they have been very influential
throughout all of history
there's sort of an epicurean revival
in the renaissance and
in the modern period a lot of people
resonate quite well with epicurus and
his followers because they say
you know atomic theory and elements that
makes a lot of sense they're
materialists
in ethics a lot of people are hedonists
meaning that they think pleasure is the
primary good
and so they kind of like epicurus for
that
cicero though thought that the
epicureans were more bluster
than real substance and so what we've
been doing up to this point is kind of
warm up you might say cicero thought
there was a lot more
to the stoic position and you notice by
the end of the dialogue even though
cicero belongs to the academic school
he says that he thinks that the stoic
guy in the dialogue baldus
was somewhat more convincing than the
other guy who just actually got the last
word who got to criticize the stone
so you know why would that be
well the stoics had a very comprehensive
kind of system
about all different matters some of them
you know being religious matters
and just to give you a little bit of
background
and we can come back to this a little
bit later on you know in in the ancient
world we often
like i said have this notion that the
greeks had their you know gods and
these olympian gods like zeus and hera
and aphrodite and aries and athena
and they all just like had their sort of
things that they did and you know we
know
some of the stories about them like zeus
like to sleep around a lot
and you know get human women pregnant
and then some of them would become gods
and someone become heroes
the hercules for example and hera didn't
like this so hare would you know try to
kill
little hercules and you know she was
kind of a jealous wife understandably so
if
zeus was a kind of a bad guy in that
respect
he actually with one of his kids like
hides him inside of his uh
his calf cuts his calf muscle up and
makes it into a womb
after hera kills that guy's mom
i think that was dionysus um you know
we have stories like aphrodite is
married to hephaestus the
the smith but he's kind of an ugly guy
and not very romantic so she actually
sleeps with
uh the god of war aries he faces his
brother
and he makes a net that will fall on
them and catches them in the act and
everybody's laughing at them a lot of
stories like this now did the greeks
actually believe
this sort of thing some of them did
how believable would you find these
stories if you were
an if you were a philosopher if you were
somebody who developed a fairly high
level of culture
is that the way you would picture the
divine
the divine consists in all these kind of
almost sitcom-like
creatures you know who are are kind of
cruel actually they mess around with
mortals
and sometimes do terrible things to them
you know it's not actually a good thing
necessarily to be loved by a god because
sometimes that can get you in
trouble as well especially if you're one
of zeus's
you know paramours
is this the way you would think of it
probably not right a lot of ancient
greeks didn't do
they said there's got to be some better
explanation than this they didn't say
it's all bs god's this whole notion
let's get rid of all of it and become
atheists
there were some atheists in the ancient
period and there were some
agnostics and and you've always got some
people who are being hypocrites too
right
but the philosophers wanted to come up
with a
a better conception of the gods or of
god
you know some of them ended up in
something like monotheism
stoicism is kind of a weird hybrid
mix as we'll see it's kind of hard to
tell you know whether they believe in
gods
or god where the gods are sort of
aspects or parts of the god um
this was very attractive to people who
were
intellectually developed what the stoics
had to offer
was a fairly comprehensive
doctrine about religious matters and
this was a time when people were
searching
they were they're really hungry for
having some sort of explanation about
about something bigger than us something
greater than just human beings
now bulbas talks about the stoics as
organizing this into four main issues
and he's crediting this to a stoic guy
named precipice
crucifix was the third
you know sort of top guy in the stoic
school
after clay anthony's and zeno who starts
the school chrysippus was was really the
guy
who did the most organization
xeno he did you know some work clanthes
was not particularly bright
but was very you know very persevering
and sort of embodied the stoic lifestyle
and then clampy's
clanthes was a brainiac and wrote book
after book after book after book
articulating the stoic position
defending it against everybody else
arguing with all these different people
he wrote he was one of the most prolific
writers of antiquity
so clay anthony is you know when you're
doing writing that much you have to
organize what you're writing right
you guys know this from writing papers
it's one thing to write about the stuff
in one
stream of consciousness you know thing
somebody else looks at they're like i
don't know what you're talking about
there's a lot of interesting stuff here
but
where is the where is the structure so
this is the structure that he gave it he
said well one thing you gotta talk about
is the existence
of gods
and you know why is this such an
important issue
why why do you think going to talk about
religion
why should you start with the existence
of the gods
or god yeah because without the gods
there is no religion at all so you have
to see whether it even exists
really you shouldn't spend a lot of time
if you're doing philosophy you shouldn't
spend a lot of time talking about things
that don't exist
you know because then you're just
wasting everybody's time you know
if there are atoms great then we can
talk about the atoms but if there's no
such thing as an
atom you know there's other ways of
explaining matter
then probably you should you know focus
on that instead so if there aren't any
gods to start with
you really don't get off the ground in
philosophy of religion
um people want to know about what they
call the nature
of the gods
okay what are the gods like what's your
what's your conception
of god is god um
sort of like a big shiny well-muscled
guy who throws lightning there's zeus
right right maybe
you're surrounded by clouds he's got a
long white beard
um is god the totem of your
your clan in in some you know indigenous
religion that's a very different
conception of god that's a different
nature
of god right um
then they wanted to talk about a couple
other things that might seem to fit into
the nature of the gods but they thought
these are special important topics
so
are the gods involved in management
you could say we've got this whole
universe around us you know physical
things
and we're a little bit detached from
that because we live in a highly
technological age
you know if we were plato we'd be having
this in a fairly open area right
actually a gymnasium where people
practice
exercise of different sorts and then you
know do some philosophy
we do it inside of a classroom the
outside is being kept
out there so we're not affected by the
weather
but it wasn't that way for the ancient
greeks they were much more connected to
the natural
world and they want to know do the gods
actually do stuff
in the natural world you know remember
these guys they don't have
the kind of science that we do you know
you guys know lightning is what
what what what happens to produce
lightning
there's energy
yeah you've got we've got this whole
conception positive and negative charges
and i forget whether the clouds are
positively charged or if it's negatively
charged or
whether it's the other way around
something science people probably know
better
i haven't looked at this for a long time
but i know that's our conception right
the greeks you know they wanted to
figure out what's going on with those
lightnings that got mad at me
um or you know is that totally natural
phenomenon disconnected from whatever it
is that we're thinking about with
religion
you know the epicureans said hey the
gods don't mess around with the universe
that's why they're happy because they
don't have jobs
the the stoic said no all this physical
stuff that's going on the gods are
actually driving it they're making that
happen
and then finally there is a part of the
universe that we're really concerned
with
do the gods care
about human beings
and human affairs um are the gods
interested in what we do
or could they you know care less
um again the epicureans hey the again
that's
why the gods are happy because they
don't
think about all of us schmucks down here
and the stupid things that we do and all
these these dumb prayers that we're you
know making to them
that are usually contradictory you know
two guys you know going to fight over
the same girl
praying for that girl i mean you know
think about the problems that the gods
would have in trying to answer prayers
all these contradictory desires being
expressed
you know maybe there is something to the
epicurean thought that the gods would be
a lot happier if they just say yeah it's
up to you
well again the stoics thought that the
gods actually do care
about human beings that
you can see this reflected not only in
the answers to prayers or divination or
things like that but in the very way in
which we're made
that the gods gave us something that
they didn't give to the other animals
that
is you know makes us different it's a
great gift
we'll get to that in a while so he
organizes things into this
sort of structure
and so we're going to start with the
question of existence first
and
as far as i can tell there's not a lot
of discussion about this there's a lot
of literature on this
there are five main arguments for the
existence of god that are being made
in this book yet specifically in this
section of cicero's on the nature of the
gods
and you might say well why do you need
arguments for the existence of god
well you know if somebody doesn't
believe that god exists
then you could convince them with that
what else might you want an argument for
whether god exists or not
you can convince somebody else who
doesn't believe this is what people call
apologetics in christian circles
what else does a person want an argument
though
yeah like maybe you view god well you
know that's interesting because the
um each one of these arguments
not only will hopefully demonstrate that
god has to exist but it
will also be a way of trying to wrap
your head around
the way god is so god's existence and
god's nature
are are connected but let's go a little
bit further let's say you were in kind
of a doubting mood
why would you want an argument yeah
reformation
of like what do you think experience
very good yeah sometimes we
make arguments to ourselves because we
were sure about something
and now we're not quite so sure and we
want to
see if we can strengthen our previous
belief so let's you know take something
a lot less
weighty than the existence of the gods
you're married to somebody
and they're coming home real late at
night frequently
and we'll make it a guy so i can
think of what was similar things i think
with a girl so
guy comes home late at night no
explanation
real cagey about it but about his phone
um
got some lipstick on his collar kind of
smells like like perfume
his hair is all messed up clothes are
kind of kind of screwed up
and this happens a couple times now his
his wife
you know should should say i wonder
what's going on
you know and she's got a belief
previously this guy's faithful right
should that be thrown into question at
that point
probably right if she if she doesn't
then we'd probably say she's a little
bit gullible
now let's say she wants to um
continue to believe that her husband is
still faithful now she might come up
with some sort of argument for
you know how these these things can be
explained
um that's probably an argument you don't
want to give yourself because
probably he is you know with these sort
of signs he probably isn't doing it but
people make arguments to themselves all
the time
we don't often think of them in terms of
arguments we think of them as like just
this process of reaffirmation there's
another case too
where you genuinely don't know and you
say i want proof
i would like to believe that there's god
that god exists that this isn't just a
bunch of fables but i
i don't know so can you can you provide
me with some sort of evidence and like
we said
when it comes down to the existence of
god you can't like just you know look
around okay
where's zeus is he is he here that's not
going to work
it's not that kind of evidence that
you're looking for
it's something that your mind can find
acceptable something that you can wrap
your head around we call that a rational
proof so he gives you five different
arguments about this one is what we call
the argumentary common consent
and we looked at this one last time with
the epicureans because they made that
argument right
is what we call the argument for
miracles
the third one is what we call the
argument from design
or sometimes it's called the
teleological
fourth one is the argument from
intelligence
and the fifth one is the argument from
degrees of being
and
very often when we're teaching this
stuff to undergraduates
um we don't begin with somebody like
cicero as a matter of fact cicero is
fairly rarely taught the main reason why
you guys are reading cicero
is because i happened to read cicero and
saw all this stuff in there and i was
like wow there's
this would be a great thing to have
people
encounter usually we'll have you read
something like you know saint anselm
and thomas aquinas and descartes yeah
can you usually do this sure um
and then you know have you come to
people who criticize these arguments
like a monument
and some of these arguments don't often
get treated by philosophers
the ones that you would encounter in a
typical philosophy textbook would
include the argument from design
um but then they would include things
like what we call the ontological
argument
and the cosmological argument and maybe
a few other ones and that would be about
it they wouldn't include some of these
because
some of these aren't very well
understood by philosophers and some of
them aren't very highly regarded by
philosophers in particular the argument
for miracles
at least in cicero's time people thought
these were
fairly decent arguments at least the
stoics did
we're going to see some of these
arguments have some real flaws but we
want to look at them
each in turn and we're not going to look
at the flaws so much today we'll look at
them
much more extensively next time i'll
point out a few things
let's start with the argument from
common consent
how does this work do you guys remember
from last class yeah it's a
kind of like a similar basis that
everybody can agree on
okay so there is something that's agreed
on what what's actually agreed on
yeah that there is like the gods exist
yeah so each culture you look at them uh
nobody's making them come up with these
ideas they're all coming up with some
sort of idea of god
and then okay the gods look different we
saw the epicureans
kind of stepped in it when they were
saying oh everybody thinks the gods have
human form because we know that's not
the case the egyptians
got these weird hybrids with you know
like a human body and then you know
like a cat or an eagle's head or
you name it you know crocodiles um
the egyptians actually had a bowl that
they worshipped as divine
you go around the world you're going to
find a lot of things that that people
are willing to
say is god the one who saves divine
but they all do have something right so
that many people can't be wrong there's
got to be something out there
that these are all tending towards
that's the argument from common consent
and you know we looked at is this a
really strong argument or not it's not
the strongest argument
what's the one weak point with it well
there's there's you know
quite a few things that we might all
believe in but it doesn't actually make
it true
um and then we looked at you guys
actually suggested some really
interesting
things like well maybe all these ideas
came from one place which
cicero didn't consider but
that's a plausible explanation for for
that phenomenon of
universal belief in something or another
in our own time this would not be a
particularly good argument because our
atheist countries
so not all cultures actually
do believe in the gods the stoics one of
the arguments
that baldus makes to reinforce this is
really interesting
he actually says you know if you look at
history what we see up until our time
and remember he's not he's not writing
in our time
you know after nietzsche said god is
dead and all that sort of stuff he's
writing back in the ancient period he's
saying
you know people are believing this more
and more and more
um look even the philosophers are
believing in this sort of stuff
so you know an idea that catches on and
seems to have some staying power that's
different from an idea
that we just kind of made up in our head
he uses the example of sensors
what are what are sent is to ours
half portion yeah and then you know they
have bows and you know they don't have
to wear any clothes of course because
the man part is you know
shirtless and the horse part's got hair
so you know they get to go around and
they some of them play music
and then some of them you know shoot
their bows at things and
and um by this time every you know
everybody who's cultured thinks
that's all bs there's no such thing as a
centaur it's a nice story
but nobody really believes in this
except for maybe some country people who
are
you know unenlightened why did the idea
die out well because it was just an
imagination
are there other imaginary things you
could think about for us
where they've kind of died out over over
time
think back to you know our treatment of
race yeah okay oh i was just gonna
you were going on to no no
things that people have believed yeah
that are just imaginary oh
like mermaids and okay yeah
mermaid is kind of the same thing you
take like the top of the human and plop
it on a fish and
there you go you know yeah like when we
were kids we believed in santa claus
and goals okay yeah yeah santa claus the
easter bunny the tooth fairy
you know we make movies with these where
they all get together and like you know
save the world or things like that
but they're imaginary the thing i was
going to say is
you know if you think about the notion
of race just the way it was about 100
years ago
where there was this belief that you had
these distinct races of human being
and each one had its own attributes and
you know if they mix together it weakens
the uh the strain and produces defective
hybrids
um a lot of people you know sort of
regulated their lives on that basis and
they had very strong emotional reactions
and you know there are still some people
i think today who
have that sort of view of race most
people
you know know something about genetics
and they know that
you can take any human being and any
other human being no matter what skin
color
eye shape facial features
build because you know actually some
some races are tall and some races are
short you know if you actually want to
get very technical about it
and you can mix them together and they
can have they can make make babies that
are that are human
we're all we're all one race you know um
the idea dies out over time and
hopefully it'll die out
altogether and just be a historical
phenomenon
is pretty deleterious to us um the idea
dies out because it's
um imaginary
a lot of people believe in things like
fairies any of you believe in fairies
the leprechauns the little people who
you know do things
okay well that there there you go the
reason you know why a lot of us
believed in that sort of thing is
probably because you know we were
gullible and we watched too many tv
shows in our generations because you
know they have all these
things when we're really little we might
actually think things on tv are real
you might think that uh cartoons are you
know different cartoon characters are
real
but it's just imagination as you get
older you get rid of that
well this idea about god that the there
is something like like a divine
something greater than us
that hasn't gone away you know this is
an interesting one to think about even
from a dare
sure there's atheist countries i'm sure
there's a lot of people who are not
religious
but you know one of the things that was
predicted about modernity
is as we get more and more modern
religion should vanish
has it has it vanished in the
even though those you know supposedly
first world modern countries
hasn't some of them church attendance in
you know
like italy france spain is like you know
in the single digits
but not everybody and and here in
america america is pretty religious
and there are other places where
religion exercises a free effect
so the stoics would look at that sort of
thing and they'd say see that's
that's an example of an idea of staying
power why does that idea have staying
power because it's not just imagination
it reflects something about our nature
it reflects something that's kind of
hardwired into us
and that's why we have this common idea
so therefore there must be something
corresponding to that
and i'm going to leave it an open
question whether that's a good argument
or not we'll we'll talk about that next
time yeah
i was just going to say there's one
thing i could go okay very solid inside
um in the past there was a strong idea
and belief in dragons like they
showed up in every almost every culture
all over the place oh
that's a good example yeah the flying
fire fire-breathing lizard
yeah and yet it showed up in european
chinese yeah even in some middle eastern
and uh
indian okay uh cultures they all
show up at one given time period yeah
and then
poof they're all gone there's
almost no physical remains of such
things even
ever existing but yeah well i mean
that'd be an interesting case in point
where you could say well just because
there's a common idea
maybe maybe that there is just
sort of a common imagination that's not
actually vertical
let's go and look at the next one now
this one philosophers in general don't
take it seriously at all
and i'm not even sure that cicero means
it to be taken seriously because
he has his academic character like you
know savagely attacked us
but the basic idea is this how do you
know that god exists
well because god does things
miraculous and two basically two
different kinds of things
one is like sometimes god shows up and
appears
or the gods you know and he's got all
these examples as well they saw this god
fighting on horseback you know this
this thing helping out the the romans or
the greeks or whoever
the other would be through god revealing
his or her its will
through what we call divination fortune
telling fortune telling not just in the
sense of like
you know some sort of vague fortune out
there but they get you know some sort of
activity
that's supposed to reveal the will of
the gods so if you're an ancient greek a
roman
you would maybe go to an oracle and ask
a question
or you would have a priest cut open
a bird and and or no look at the flights
of birds or cut open a sacrificial
victim and look at his liver
and you know look at the different spots
there was like a system for that
augury which actually some of the
priests even thought was laughable
you might cast lots you know in the
bible
the umami and thurim that the priests
would
would actually throw to you know divide
the will of the
hebrew god those were dice basically
and they would throw them in chinese
they have the book of changes
and that's casting coins or euro stocks
and you
you know somehow you connect this up
with
god revealing himself or rehearsals or
whatever
or god's will for for human beings
now the idea is this
you couldn't have that kind of
experience if there wasn't a god
people have that kind of experience
therefore there's a god
well that sounds pretty simple doesn't
it do you see any problems with this
and any objections that somebody might
raise yeah
well i mean anybody can say hey i had
this
divine sight and now i believe in god
type of thing but
they could just be making that up for
the seasons or
just to get their 15 minutes
okay so people want attention and maybe
they do that yeah
um everything like you can't explain
seems miraculous but like once you have
an explanation behind it it's really not
yeah that's another problem too
you know there's all sorts of
issues that come up with this um you
know the sailors
at one point cicero says the sailors who
died at sea
when they were praying they didn't leave
any any you know
counter offerings in the temple saying
hey that god didn't do a thing for me
you know where are you gonna stay i was
just gonna say
um as far as like today is concerned and
medicine
and like the way people are cured and
healed
that's i think when i think of the
miracles concept because
um not as much then but more so now
because we have so many like advances in
technology and research and science
there are still things that happen all
the time that are documented
in research and online and in all
different types of databases that
uh medical recoveries are unexplainable
yeah yeah exactly and things could
always happen by chance with the human
body but
for them to happen in all those
different types of instances where
somebody could just be cured in all
these different types of
ways all different types of people care
about all different types of so you're
making our ventures are you with the
strength of us
yeah okay yeah yeah i was just gonna say
that
the mind sees what it wants to see in
some regards
so there's a problem too interpretation
in order to see a miracle as a miracle
because two people could be looking at
the same thing and one says yeah a
miracle took place and i wasn't
i don't see it somehow you have to be
kind of engaged in this and cicero
doesn't really worry that much about
about that in part because he's got
other reasons for attacking
attacking this particular argument
um but he seems to think this is kind of
a lightweight argument
a lot of people you know um in religious
circles
seem to view this as a
a good argument but it might be more
along the lines of what you're talking
about where it reveals
the nature of god rather than actually
proving that god exists necessarily
now when we get to design here we get
into something that has some
metaphysical
depth and here's the basic idea
of the design argument so there's a lot
of design arguments out there people are
still making these today
when you hear about people talking about
intelligent design
as opposed to creationism but also as
opposed to evolution
um that's the concept of design that
we're thinking of here
that there would be some sort of
intelligent designer
who arranged all the things in the
universe and made them
be the way that they are and if you
again if you
if you are a scientist and you start
looking at
just you know the eye and the evolution
of the eye darwin always said this is
one of my real
trouble points i always want to stay
away from that in conversation
because a lot of things i can explain
pretty easily by natural selection
the eyeball that's a toughie
you know why because so many things have
to happen
in order for this wonderful just amazing
bit of like wet wear technology in our
our heads to have the capacities that it
does just think about what your eye can
do
you know and then compare it to the
eyeballs that you know
much lower animals have
you know we don't just sense light and
put together images you have this whole
range of color
right you can discriminate all these
different beautiful colors
what's doing the job for that these
weird little rods and cones in the back
of it
you know there's all this optical stuff
that's taking place
i mean we know about this because then
we can produce you know things to
actually help out
if i take this off there's a bunch of
blurs colorful bores but just blurs put
this on
and now things are the way they're
supposed to be with these eyeballs and
now you're all
back to being you know sharp
identifiable human beings again that i
can tell apart from each other
other than the colors of your clothes
and hair and faces and things like that
um so you know think about all sorts of
other things too
think about how adapted the life or
you know think about how many things had
to come together in the right way
in order to just get life started and
then to continue and sustain it
doesn't it seem as if they're this
reflects
some sort of complexity and
maybe something like an intentional
design things are designed to do these
sorts of things they have functions
maybe they're not all designed the best
way their their mistakes made every once
in a while
and maybe some of the things are
designed in such ways that they screw up
other things they think about viruses
and have you ever like look into what a
virus really is
it's an amazing thing it's a terrible
thing
which we didn't have them but they're
also amazing
you know the virus really is a bit of
protein
surrounding some genetic code and that
genetic code
gets used by the virus to make the the
virus later on
it'll latch onto a cell and the protein
shell is just
you know basically to protect it and it
gets to the shell and then it like
injects that code and that code
goes in and seeks out the cell's own
code
inserts itself and changes that code and
you know what it changes it
to make it do more make more viruses
right this is why the computer virus is
analogous to a biological virus and it
takes the cell over and turns it into a
big virus
production factory cell stops doing all
the other stuff and then the cell
explodes and all these little viruses go
off
that's pretty cool that's you know
there's
a lot of things going on there that um
you know you can investigate and there's
all this this you know
complexity and it looks like almost
intentional design to it now think about
things that we have
in the human world i'm not going to use
the iphone because i've used that too
many too many times
it's an example already think about
these right
what what is this keyring
and so obviously it's got keys on it and
you've got two car keys and one of the
card clickers and
then all what are these things
discount cards yeah or like my library
cards on here too
and you know you can scan these i have a
lot of this
crap now that i look at it
i shop in a lot of places apparently
just keep accumulating these as you get
older
why are these keys
the way they are car keys used to look
different than this yeah
would that be like at that point in time
like the human's perception of
perfection for that object maybe i don't
know if the ford company like said we
want the perfect
car key because ford doesn't do anything
perfectly
it's like that i'm a ford user you know
but yeah they designed it
um and i think it's supposed to be kind
of you know fitting
your hand nicely i i like these keys
better
when i i'm a person who doesn't like
change
and so when these keys first came out i
was like this is crap i can't stand
these you know
now i actually kind of i see why they're
a lot easier to hold when
it's cold or wet or stuff like that it's
kind of nice to have
it's also nice to have this clicker
thing i hated this when it first came
out
you know but now i understand its
purpose yeah students say it's whatever
is aesthetically pleasing to the
population at the time so i'm pretty
sure they go out and get like a thousand
people
through surveys do surveys or hand them
out and say hey which one do you prefer
yeah now notice what's going on here
there's intentional design
they set this up in this way for a
reason
even the key ring itself why are all
these keys on here so i have them all in
one place
when i need them i even have my library
card on here you know when i need it i
can just shove it in my pocket now i'm
good to go
so there's an intentional design the
argument by from design
works by saying look there's a
there's a similarity between what human
beings do
and the way we assemble things and the
way the world
as a whole and the things in it are the
natural things
this didn't happen by chance
somebody designed things this way
similarly there must be some
not you know godlike divine designer who
created all these other natural
phenomena
that's the argument from design so when
people are talking about intelligent
design they're talking about that kind
of
designer would be
god or the gods
everybody clear about that that's got
some you know philosophers a lot of them
don't accept that a lot of philosophers
do accept that that's
that's one that's had some some real
staying power yeah
so with the idea of design it's
following the idea of since things fit
together so perfectly it must be by
design
instead of by say just a chance or
just a problem random annotation or yeah
it's it's there's a problem with this
but i want to put that problem off until
next
next class session let's let's move to
the argument from intelligence now
so this is an argument that doesn't get
made an awful lot in philosophy
textbooks
and doesn't seem to be particularly well
understood by a lot of
present-day philosophers of religion but
was quite popular back in the ancient
period
both among the pagans and then later
among
you know jews christians muslims
and here's how it works
what's really distinctive about us is
having
reason or intelligence however you want
to conceive of it
there's kind of a quantum leap from from
the other animals to us
we have a lot of other things in common
with the desire being aware of our
surroundings
needing to eat reproduce all that sort
of stuff but we have rationality
and it's easy to explain where all the
other things about us came from
where'd all this meat and bones that i'm
carrying around come from
you know from the physical elements that
were put together in certain ways
that's easy enough to explain um the
greeks often
when you see this in this argument tend
to think of the the psyche
or the soul as being you know kind of
like a a breath or a spirit
the stoics were material so they
actually did see it that way
where did that come from maybe from the
winds you know because that's that's
that kind of thing
where did intelligence come from could
it have come from lower things that were
not themselves intelligent
well do you get higher things
coming from higher things in an
ontological sense better
greater you know having
more active capacities do you get those
coming from a lower thing
or do they need to come from something
like themselves
well we didn't make ourselves
intelligent
so our intelligence itself must have
come from
something else that's intelligent so
it's not going to be coming from
something below us
plants animals rocks
biphones things like that that's a
product right
it's got to come from something else
something
divine since it's not human it's going
to have to be
divine we came from some at least that
part of ourselves that's intelligent
came from a divine intelligence
now the stoics we're going to talk about
this in a moment they didn't understand
god as like being
outside of the world the way jews
christian muslims you know monotheists
do a transcendent god they understood as
god as being the world
so that meant that the world itself had
to be
intelligent in some sense and this leads
to some some you know
kind of weird paradoxes that we'll talk
about next time
because the academics are going to say
that doesn't make any sense
but the idea was that
the only way in which we can explain the
existence of our own intelligence
which is something that we understand by
using what by using our intelligence
the only way in which we can actually
even understand the origin of our own
intelligence
is by seeing it in some cause that is
itself intelligent
which would have to be god this is an
interesting argument
this is something worth wrapping your
head around whether you accept it or
don't accept it
because one of the things that we do
want to be able to explain is where did
we get this
this you know big brain crop and not
just the brain but the
all the activities that go with them and
we'll look at that again next
next class as well the degrees of being
argument
is based on a notion that you might not
buy
it's also based on this notion that was
fairly widespread in antiquity
and in the middle ages that there are
degrees of being so
you start out with just like their being
like you know what this paper has
it's not alive it's not sentient it's
definitely not rational
it exists right but its kind of
existence is a lower kind of existence
than say
something that's alive so the virus
that's
you know in in every one of your systems
every one of you is carrying some sort
of virus
you know whether you're sick or not uh
we're all carrying bacteria and viruses
those are in a certain sense greater
beings in this paper
even though they're literal physically
they're greater in that they have a
higher degree of being
and function they right they have a
function they can take in other things
they they live
they experience as we get higher and
higher and higher
up we we get away from the merely you
know viruses don't really think a lot
they don't really do much of anything
other than make new viruses
that die and they don't even really die
in a real sense either
they're that close to the mineral world
um
we get to the animal world now you know
you think about your dog or your cat
it loves you sometimes it hates you
you know when you stand in the way of
what it wants uh
it might even be like you giving an
attention because you're looking at a
book or something like that
it looks around it hunts
it plays that's a higher degree of being
than a virus
now you are at a yet higher degree of
being
because you're a rational being you're
not a mere animal
you are an animal you know we never want
to forget that fact we are
animals we do have all these desires
drives you know
corporeality but there's something to
you that's at a higher degree of being
has greater ontological dignity or
density or however you want to want to
conceive of it metaphysically
are you the highest that's the question
are you the top of the metaphysical
food chain you might say or is there
anything higher than you
the argument from the degrees of being
works by saying
look if you're going to have this whole
notion of degrees of being there has to
be some top
level and it's got to be something that
is absolutely perfect
yeah something that is you know just
the best exemplar of everything in this
this ladder
now ask yourself this about your
rationality are you perfectly rational
have you ever done anything irrational
do you
have to learn sometimes from your
mistakes
so you're not you're not the top are you
you could think you are but if you do
then you're you're you know
a narcissist you're nuts because you're
not the top there's got to be something
higher something better than you and
that has to exist not just in
our imagination that has to actually
exist
in order for this whole chain of beings
this whole metaphysical set of
postulates to
to work again this is this is also a
very
interesting proof um
some people say yeah this makes sense
other people say i can't even
understand what this is about depending
on what your
philosophical commitments are and
the stoics definitely bought into this a
lot of people in ancient and medieval
times bought into it
um i myself actually i'll level with you
i in fact i'm i'm a a platoonist of
sorts and
i believe there are degrees of being
that's a unpopular view among
present-day philosophers
so i'm more tempted to believe in this
this argument than other people might be
a lot of modern-day philosophers that
say this doesn't this notion of degrees
of being doesn't really make
any sense since
their ontology is kind of a flat
ontology but if you if you have this
notion of degrees of being then you can
get an argument for god's existence out
of it
again not a god that's outside of the
world for the stoics
but a god who's somehow the world itself
or
uh imminent so now is actually a good
time to
move away from these proofs and and tell
you a little bit about
their notion of god because i think this
as you're reading through this text this
is probably something that would confuse
you
so
this is the world or the animals
all right familiar concepts here from
from cosmology from
your earth science classes and things
like that
and here's
human beings um just a tiny little part
of
the world and we exist on
the earth which has all these natural
processes going on
we should put human much smaller because
we're you know just a tiny part of it
and the way that they understood the
universe was there were these
these other things stars you know
out there and
um stoics were already a little kind of
fuzzy about this
but you know you'd have to be fuzzy back
then all right because we didn't have
the the astronomical capabilities that
we did and this isn't a bad
implausible idea at least you got a
round world that's in the middle
you know rather than a flat earth um
and the stoics here's the way
you know you could think of things for
for like a christian or
muslim or jewish perspective god is
somehow
outside of this whole thing and
creates everything gets the whole ball
rolling makes everything
the way it is and you know it gets a
little tricky because is god you know
like
in some weird place outside of the
universe no because god you know
in traditional theology is imminent he
was present at every point in the
universe at every time but he's also
transcendent to it
for the stoics that's not the case
so the thing that we would think of as
analogous to god with a capital g
is actually
the whole world or the universe
and the whole world or the universe
possesses these divine attributes that
we
typically in our culture attribute to
this you know
transcendent notion of god so being all
powerful
rational
ascension
being good
you know being the whole ball of wax
being the top the top thing
and you know we human beings are we are
we good
some of the time right all of you have
some goodness in you
probably quite a bit you know probably
some of you quite a bit more than i do
um are you good all the time
no and are you are you going to reach
some point in your life
where you by your you know dent of your
hard effort
and constant discipline are good all the
time and never ever ever
do anything wrong probably not
if you do that's great even the saints
you know
have bad days and tell people off
sometimes
you know they're not always saintly in
every single respect right
um god would be though
god would be totally good god did not
have any sort of restrictions on god's
goodness
the way that we do same thing with
rationality god would be
totally rational i when i was a math
major
i used to think of god as sort of
the the being that i could answer all of
the problems that in mathematics we
can't solve
because there are unsolvable problems in
mathematics
and god would have the answer to those
and then if i was good
and got to heaven i've always got you
know sort of screwball ideas about why i
want to get to heaven
they're never the sort of catechism
thing of because i want to be with god
so i can love
you know love god and you know worship
god through all eternity it's more like
more like socrates i want to get the
answers to the questions that i don't
have and if i
if i go to the good place that i'm
likely to get those answers if i go to
the bad place maybe
it's the bad place in parks i'll never
get those answers i want
you know i want to go to heaven in part
because um
saint anselm was there and i want to i
want to pester him
and find out you know make him talk to
me about you know some of the stuff that
he wrote about that i'm still puzzled
about
you know either that or i want to see
the people that you know i'm fairly
confident they're up there
that i miss or things like that those
aren't particularly good reasons
from you know traditional christian
doctrine perspective
but yeah it would make sense for a stoic
there isn't any heaven for a stomach
though there's just
the universe that you're a part of right
um
god would be all powerful too because
what's more powerful than the universe
nothing i mean the universe does what
it's going to do inside of itself
so think of god as like the entire
universe
rational there's like a uh an
intelligence
and intentionality pervading everything
that makes things go the way that they
are
that arranges things for the best
doesn't necessarily look that way to us
but but that's the way that
it worked that's what called providence
providential ordering
then you might say well then what are
all these other gods how does that
business fit in and that's where it gets
really messy
because there's all these let's call
them god
with a small gene right and
from the historic perspective well you
got to have these little goblets
organizing the universe and doing you
can think of them as sort of like having
delegate
delegated powers you know um
and this is you know this is where it
gets very very tricky
how do they fit in together that's not
explained but the idea is
there there is god and then there's gods
we might think of these if you're
inclined towards traditional
christian or muslim or jewish theology
we might think of these as some
being something like angels because
that's the job that angels did
in some of these older medieval
theologies
but the stoics had these gods who all
participate in the working of the
universe
so what about like zeus and things like
that well those are just
allegories what what's an allegory you
guys
know this term it's a story
is it meant to be true yeah
aren't they just looking like
representative figures or something yes
so an allegory is a story that really
tells another deeper story
and the original story is not supposed
to be true like the boy who cried wolf
was there really a little boy who cried
wolf a whole bunch of times
and then the neighbors finally got got
tired of his bs
and when the real wolf came they said
screw him let the wolf eat him
he's probably you know joking around
with us again
no but is that supposed to teach you
something
what's it supposed to teach you is it
only about crying wolf how many times
have you guys
run into that situation where oh there's
a wolf i better
better cry wolf what is it teaching you
about
something broader right what is it
teaching me about
yeah not to make up stories and to be
honest
yeah especially stories about what you
need or want or things like that or
danger
because then when you really do need
something everybody's going to be tired
of you by that point they're not going
to listen to you
that's the deeper meaning that's the
real meaning
so the stoics thought when it came to
all the myths and legends and stuff like
that
that was what was going on allegories
the real stuff is
is this all of these
things are working on
the universe and taking care of it and
they're all interested in making it the
best that it can possibly be
and there's some problems with this why
are things so screwed up
that's that's a question you might want
to ask right and the stoics would say
well it only looks screwed up from where
you're sitting
if you could really see how things are
are arranged
and sort of like you know choose to fit
yourself into this
this scheme you'd probably actually be a
lot happier with the way it's arranged
so this is an explanation of not only
god's nature
but also about something that we're
going to call
oops
the odyssey this is a term that's worth
knowing
and we're going to use it a couple other
times in the semester
if there is a god why are things the way
they are
as screwed up as they appear to be what
are
theo the odyssey comes from theos
meaning god
and hodos which means path
or wave and so it's a study it's an
explanation of the ways of god
and people ask this in religions don't
they why do good things happen to bad
people and bad things happen good people
that's a the theodical
that's a question of theodicy i'm not
even sure what the right word would be
uh you know difficult question
um i don't know
the article yeah i suppose that would
work
the stoics had an explanation in their
scheme of things
this may not be attractive to you it was
attractive to many people in ancient
times
one of the things that you got out of
this is the gods actually
care about how things are
the gods actually you're living in a
universe that's not
hostile to you it may appear hostile at
times but it's not really hostile to you
it's really been set up for your benefit
because human beings are you know
they're not the very top of the food
chain right the ontological food chain
there's the divine above them but
they're the top as far as everything
else goes
all this other stuff is there for
rational preachers gods and
human beings the gods also care about
human beings
even to the level of being able to
reveal to them what they want human
beings to do or to look out for
that's what this divination stuff that
the stoics were so into
was supposed to be about so
you have a very interesting conception
here right does
do you see now how these different
things fit in
with each other are these arguments for
god's existence which actually do reveal
something about god's nature
and then you've got this whole
conception of what we call
cosmology study of how the world
is arranged
the next book is going to be a tax on
this
so the stoics now got to present their
position and now the academic
kata is going to tear down as much as
you possibly can
and do some other stuff in the process
too so that's what we'll leave a lot